joe biden qui sera donc demain genève
pour rencontrer vladimir poutine la
ville suisse qui se barricadent vous le
voyez à moins de 24 heures de la
rencontre
un entretien qui devrait se dérouler à
la villa à la grande comme vous le voyez
sur ces images de préparatifs
même si rien n'est encore officiellement
confirmé geneve donc sous très haute
sécurité on voit cela avec notre envoyé
spécial sur place olivier de camon flec
[Musique]
bonjour olivier ravi de vous retrouver
dans la matinale berthet france alors on
l'a vu sur ces images la ville de genève
s'active pour organiser la rencontre
entre joe dalton et vladimir poutine oui
bonjour
magali alors effectivement vous vous en
doutez un dispositif de sécurité
particulièrement important
particulièrement hors norme a ici pour
accueillir cette rencontre entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden alors ce
rendez vous diplomatique est là et bien
il a été placé au niveau de menace
élevée 1 par les autorités par
conséquent ce sont 2000 policiers du
canton de genève qui sont mobilisés ça
représente 95% des effectifs
à cela s'ajoute 900 policiers des
cantons aux alentours et puis l'armée
elle elle a déployé et bien mille
militaires alors à la fois un pour
assurer la logistique mais également
pour assurer la sécurité de l'aéroport
qui se trouve à quelques kilomètres
derrière moi mais également la sécurité
du lac léman au togo à bord duquel je me
retrouve je me trouve actuellement
alors il ya une zone qui est
particulièrement sensible vous le disiez
c'est celle qui est aux abords du parc
la grange c'est là bas que les deux
hommes vont se rencontrer demain alors
tout autour il ya deux kilomètres de
barbelés qui ont été installés vous le
voyez c'est un véritable camp retranché
alors on a pu s'entretenir avec quelques
genevois pour comprendre comment ils
vivaient cette rencontre et bien si
effectivement leur quotidien et déjà
impacté 1 puisqu'il ya des tramways qui
ne circule déjà plus de lignes au moins
eh bien il reste heureux que genève soit
le centre du monde
à partir de demain que la suisse renoue
finalement
avec cette longue tradition en matière
d'accueil et de médiation alors en tout
cas dès aujourd'hui il y à une zone
autour de laquelle on ne peut plus
circuler ni à pied ni en voiture et
c'est celle aux abords de l'hôtel
intercontinental il est un peu excentré
de la position je me trouve
il se situe à 5 km de l'aéroport et
c'est là bas que joe biden doit arriver
dans l'après midi le président américain
dont qui ce qui séjournera à l'hôtel
intercontinental
on suivra son arrivée bien évidemment
pour vous sur rc france magali et en
direct et on sera heureux de vous
retrouver tout au long de cette édition
spéciale qui sera à partir de demain à
l'antenne sur rt france et on a
également notre correspondant à moscou
qui suivra de près cette rencontre de
l'intérieur merci beaucoup olivier de 40
flec